we begin with a landmark meeting between
two of the world's most powerful leaders
President Joe Biden and China's
president Xi Jinping they spoke for
about three hours in Indonesia this
morning ahead of the upcoming G20 Summit
U.S officials say the conversation
ranged from taiwan's future to Russia's
war in Ukraine and the leaders agreed to
work together Nancy Cordes is in Bali
for us traveling with the presidents
where we find her Nancy good morning
the morning the meeting lasted for more
than three hours afterwards President
Biden told us he's not looking for
conflict and he believes a cold war can
be avoided despite years of warnings and
threats
I just met in person with Xi Jinping of
the People's Republic of China he was
clear and I was clear that we'll defend
American interests and values promote
Universal human rights and stand up for
the international order and work in
lockstep with our allies and partners
we're going to compete vigorously but
I'm not looking for conflict I'm looking
to manage this competition responsibly
the leaders of the world's two largest
economies sat at long tables facing each
other the two Nations at odds over trade
technology Chinese spying human rights
and China's growing aggression towards
Taiwan
[Applause]
in recent months China has flown
military planes near the self-governed
island firing missiles into the
surrounding Waters when house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi traveled to Taiwan this
summer the Chinese retaliated by cutting
off communication with U.S officials I
think both sides realize that if we keep
going down the path that we're headed on
that will be conflict China expert Scott
Kennedy says Russia's invasion of
Ukraine is also on the agenda the
Chinese initially stood by Russia but
that was before Ukraine began taking
back territory they know where their
economic bread is buttered with the West
not with Russia Today president XI
argued they can both do better
the world expects that China and the
United States will properly handle the
relationship
Russia is also a member of the G20 but
President Biden will not have an
opportunity to confront Russian
President Vladimir Putin at this Summit
in Bali and that's because Putin has
decided not to attend in the face of his
faltering invasion of Ukraine Tony
faltering his word for it Nancy quarters
for us at Bali Nancy thank you